mm-hmm i would just capture the pawn  don't even need to think about it twice  wow it's getting close for a niche geary  his very first victory  in the meltwater champions chester this  is a big one  yeah this could uh be a boost for his  whole career  okay he goes after a pawn and now he  re-roots his rook  note how black's rook is defending the  pawn in front of black's king that's the  only real target for the white rooks  and now um anish gary he's going to give  check and i can push his pawn forward if  he's been mean  yep um if any shigeru wants to win this  game he will push his pawn forward maybe  he doesn't need to  okay there we go yeah and he's going to  be he's won the tournament anushkiri is  the champion  it's over aneesh giri is the winner of  the magnus crossing invitational  not giving any reaction away here but he  must be  so thrilled what an inc